welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka poon knight in this
video we're breaking down the new
moonlight tv sport shown at the super
bowl this new trailer has lots of never
before seen footage that makes it look
like one of the best marvel shows that
we've ever had throughout this video
we're going to be pointing out all the
hidden details in it and also going over
our thoughts on what could be happening
if you enjoy it then please hit the
thumbs up button and also don't forget
to subscribe for videos like this every
day without the way a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into moon
knight okay so the tv spot opens with
the marvel studios logo rotating like
the hands of a clock and this has been
done for a specific reason moonlight is
very much a creature of the night like
your girlfriend who operates when the
sun goes down just kidding you don't
have a girlfriend you lose a happy
valentine's day however we know from the
first trailer that steven grant also has
trouble sleeping so ties in with the
time that he spends at night awake
playing with a rubik's cube we've seen
shots of him tying himself to the bed
and he's also unsure over what's a dream
and what's reality in case you don't
know the character oscar isaacs is plain
has dissociative identity disorder and
he's torn between his multiple
personalities these include steven grant
who we've spent the majority of the
trailers with mark spector and jake
lockley mark spector was a mercenary and
after an excursion in egypt that left
him at death's door he was brought back
to life by the god kunchu told that he'd
be his avatar on earth mark became moon
knight and the rest is history now when
the trailer first dropped we put a video
out discussing how we think that when
mark goes over the cliff in the teaser
that he's saved by the snap though many
people believed he'd simply transform
into moonlight we know from the
character's rich history that this
rarely happens in the day thus i came up
with the theory that he got snapped away
and then when he was brought back the
character wound up safely on the ground
this is because the russos discussed the
mechanics of the blip and they said that
if you were in the air mid-flight and
got snapped you would be brought back
grounded so that you just wouldn't
appear and fall to your death however
the opening of the tv spot seems to end
that theory as we catch konshu behind
him konshu has brought the character
back to life at several points and in
the charlie houston 2007 run he stalked
mark often bragging about this now marks
of their identity jake lockley was a cab
driver he created to attack street level
crime lastly is stephen grant who seems
to be the persona in all of the
marketing and he'll likely be the main
person we see things through the eyes of
he's a rich guy with a cave who has a
cool plane and gadgets and fancy metal
boomerangs that come back but he's not
batman yeah he's not batman now mark
often jumps back and forth between his
personas and he has no idea how he got
to that point or what's led up to it
it's kind of like when you switch
characters on gta 5 and trevor's just
randomly in the desert this definitely
happens in the scene after the truck one
as he's wearing the same clothes when he
goes over the cliff as when he's driving
it konchu is a terrifying figure that
will constantly stalk the character and
we know from the first trailer that he
follows him wherever he goes in the
charlie houston run he even appeared as
his nemesis ralph bushman and
antagonized him throughout the run
bushman was on the mission with him in
egypt that went awry and this led to
mark being at death's door in the
houston run he killed him and then
ripped his face off which is why
conscious appears looking like nicolas
cage when he wanted to take his face off
now stephen constantly tries to delay or
ignore the call of konchu and he
transforms seemingly against his will in
this spot we see him shouting whilst
kicking a mirror and if you watched our
first trailer breakdown then you'll know
that mirrors appeared throughout it
there was a scene where steven left the
museum at night and two of his
reflections remained behind likely
symbolizing mark and jake later on in
the bathroom scene which we know is
where moonlight fights a jackal you can
also catch a reflection standing there
staring at him i believe that this is
mark constantly trying to get out and
that he'll appear in mirrors along with
jake talking to him this will give oscar
isaacs the chance to do a sort of norman
osborne thing where he goes back and
forth in a mirror and has scenes
wrestling with his personalities mark
seems to be a mystery that steven
doesn't know about and therefore makes
sense that he's completely repressing
him the phone call that he had in the
first trailer brought this up and it
also had an image of either a crocodile
or alligator which somewhat ties into
our theory about what's going on with
arthur harrow now we get a good look at
harrow in this tv spot who seems to have
a mysterious connection to steven in the
comics arthur harrow carried out human
experiments and he'd done this dating
all the way back to the holocaust in the
80s he was working on quote-unquote pain
research and he was helped by a
mysterious organization which led him
into conflict with moon knight show
vision seems to be markedly different
and is possible that he's the embodiment
of a god much like how moon knight is at
one point we see moving scales on his
arm and if you look at the top of these
they have crocodile heads on them this
could be the god amit who had the head
of a crocodile and it was deemed unruly
by anubis and he got nicknamed the
davara of souls in the comics moon i
clashed with a character called dr remit
who was really amit so there is
precedent there in the source material
anubis the god of the dead would also
weigh a dead person's heart to see if
they were worthy to enter the underworld
and the scales could be referring to
that harrow seems to have special
abilities as we see him with the scepter
and potentially he's the character
shooting the purple lightning into the
sky purple magic has appeared throughout
the mcu and we've often discussed how it
pulls from the dark dimension this was
shown at the end of doctor strange and
also on agatha harkness who tap into the
dimension when casting spells now harrow
can also hear the voices in steven's
head so yeah that's the direction i
think they'll be going a crocodile also
appeared in the first trailer when we
could catch one in the museum and yeah
god amit it's him puns are still golden
now there is the possibility that he's a
combination of other moonlight
characters as harrow hasn't really
appeared that much in the comics ethan
hawk has also stated that he looked at
cult leaders like david koresh to mold
his character and from the first trailer
we know people are willing to bow before
him in a recent ish issue of moon knight
number 189 moonai tangled with a cult
leader called the sun king who was an
avatar on earth either way there's heavy
themes towards gods in the teasers and
in the recent runs konchu has been
expanded upon along with the rest of the
egyptian pantheon they are revealed to
have been in the other void and they
basically just use humans as their
playthings seeing gods on earth using
humans as avatars to fight would be
pretty exciting and really expand upon
the egyptian myths we also catch shots
of stephen in egypt and in a temple
which might be his mcu origin or he
could be returning to egypt in order to
fight arthur harrow now there's a reason
that some of the show takes place in the
british museum as it houses the world's
largest collection of egyptian antiques
a key item could be there which is why
both harrow and moonai are there and it
could be moonai trying to stop harrow
from obtaining something to unlock the
pyramids pyramid iconography appears
throughout the trailer and when we get
that cool cape shot you can also catch a
pyramid to the right of it it looks a
bit like the glass one at the louvre and
i'm sure that this is probably a real
location so let me know if you're
familiar with it inside it there's a
pyramid and yet pyramids permits
pyramids when he transforms we can also
catch the top of a spire which looks
like a pyramid and as i've been saying
it's all connected now museums make up a
lot of the teasers and interestingly the
british museum was also used for the
illuminati base in the multiverse of
madness trailer it seems the theme of
phase 4 is museums with the eternals
partly taking place in the natural
history one located in london blade also
came across dane whitman there in the
post credits scene so there's
potentially lots of callbacks all tying
in with museums now we know from the
press release that stephen will also don
has missed a night costume at some point
and it's going to be really interesting
to see how this is tied in potentially
it might be the suit of one of his many
personalities i'd love it if each one
had their own costume we also learned in
these releases that moon knight will be
a lot more brutal as kevin feige has
stated it pushes the boundaries of
violence in the mcu this could open up
the creatures of the night aspect of the
marvel universe as we know blade and
black knight are coming that pretty much
wraps it up and what i love about the
trailer is that moon knight looks unlike
anything disney and marvel have put out
which makes it so exciting as the movies
head into wild fan service which isn't
necessarily a bad thing this seems to be
off doing its own sort of thing i
absolutely love the teaser and the moon
iconography in it we get mk catching a
moonerang and there's also a moon that's
the same shape in the night sky there's
an awesome cape shot which looks like it
and the teaser ends with him jumping
across the sky with the moon in the
background m-o-o-n that spells moon and
i love this new teaser did you catch the
pyramid by the moon rang is there
anything we missed let me know your punk
in the comment section below we are in a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the june box set on the
28th of feb and all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness trailer which
will be linked on screen right now we go
over everything that we found in it and
talk about all the theories we have on
the movie so definitely go head over
there right after this without the way
thanks for sticking through the video
i've been paul you've been the best i'll
see you next time take care peace